after well over a thousand cases of
heart inflammation among otherwise
healthy young men after receiving the
covid vaccines
the fda is finally adding a warning
about the risks
that this experimental drug poses to
young people's hearts according to
reports
but the public health agencies are also
still telling all the healthy young
people
to take the vaccine that is very bad
government and republicans are taking
matters into their own hands
on the vaccine mandates on big tech on
critical race theory on much much more
to wield the government for good
i know we're not ever supposed to say
that but that's what's going on
the squishes will wail sensible people
are celebrating
i'm michael knowles and this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment yesterday from the
enforcer who says dying from covid19
does not scare me nearly as much
as voting democrat after i'm dead yes
that
that is a great fear that you know i i
don't encourage living your life in fear
specifically of a virus but uh the
political consequences when you're
you've been in the ground for several
years they could be very dire
you know if you want to take matters
into your own hands on all these sorts
of things especially when it comes to
fixing up your car or truck
i would strongly recommend rock auto so
i recently had this issue
with a car part that needed to be
replaced and i thought
i thought you know okay so what could i
do i could go into the brick and mortar
car parts store
and i'm going to get peppered with all
those questions that i'm not going to
know the answer to and then the guy is
going to go into the back
probably into an empty room and then
he's gonna fuss around on the computer
probably on rockauto.com order the part
i'm gonna have to wait and he's gonna
charge me twice as much
should i do that or should i go to
rockauto.com
where the catalog is so simple to
navigate that even i can do it
rockquarter.com that always has the
lowest prices
it's there's no gimmicks there's no you
got order on tuesday morning or
no none of that just go to rockauto.com
it's a family business serving auto
parts customers online
for 20 years head on over there right
now you can shop
from all of the manufacturers all the
parts that you need
rockauto.com see those parts right now
and write
knowles k-w-l-e-s in their how'd you
hear about us box so that they know
that we that i sent you according to
reports the fda
is expected to quote move rapidly to add
warning labels to the pfizer and moderna
vaccines
following the emergence of heart
inflammation cases so this is
myocarditis
this is pericarditis after receiving
these mrna vaccines
this this according to dr doran fink
uh this follows the cdc's report
which is something that we've been
covering on this show for weeks now
maybe
maybe more than weeks now actually that
there are these cases popping up
of otherwise healthy young men having an
inflammation of the heart
some of you may have heard anecdotal
incidents of this
i have heard anecdotal incidents from
friends of mine and
of course you would say the plural of
anecdote is not data well the cdc is
reporting
1200 cases of heart inflammation
occurring primarily in young men
after receiving specifically the mrna
vaccine so not the the j and j
but the the newer vaccine technology
the advisory panel of the cdc said there
is quote a likely association
between this heart inflammation and the
mrna vaccines
which which attempts to teach cells to
make a protein that triggers an
immune response okay am i going to be
kicked off of youtube for saying that i
don't know
because there are many instances now of
people being censored on big tech
platforms
for simply reporting the science it's
not like i'm even reporting
some controversial study from some
little-known
organization or journal i'm talking
about what the cdc is reporting
and what the fda is now signaling it is
going to do
but but any time it's not anytime you
you
question the science i'm not questioning
the science i'm actually reading the
signs
seems like any time you question the
official
leftist political narrative on the
lockdowns and on
on the virus then you you are liable to
be censored
alex berenson who is this journalist
who's been doggedly
covering the the virus uh he
he just tweeted out his analysis of some
new studies so
he writes cdc posted its myocarditis
pericarditis update
they're now admitting that post-second
dose risks
in people under 25 could be over 200
times the background rate
and that's not not accounting for under
reporting
so 200 times what you would expect for
this condition
in young people for people who've had
this vaccine the the real news is even
worse he says
here's stratification by your patient as
you can see the post-second-dose cases
double from age 25 to 21
then they double again in the 16 to 18
range so the younger you are according
to his analysis
of the cdc data the younger you are the
higher your risk from this heart
inflammation
after the vaccines the expansion of the
public health state
is the troubling thing to me
everything's being called public health
now
racism is a public health emergency in
chicago
guns are a public health and where
everything is a public health emergency
so the gop is going in thankfully
and attempting to correct some of this
stuff the republicans
in the house are working on a bill
that would not only stop the federal
government from requiring
the vaccines from from mandating say a
vaccine passport
but it actually would go in to ban
businesses
from requiring the vaccine this is going
to trouble some libertarians
this is going to trouble some
conservatives who came of age
in say 2011 you know those the halcyon
years
of like eight or nine years ago in
republican politics where we were told
anytime the government interferes with
business that's tyranny that's an
incursion on our liberty that's
illegitimate
well in this case it would seem to me
government interfering with
business is actually protecting my
liberty namely the liberty
not to get the vaccine so this bill is
called the vaccine
passport prevention act it would quote
bar the federal government
from issuing any form of vaccine
passport it would ban
states from doing the same as a
condition of receiving federal funds
and crucially it would bar businesses
connected to interstate commerce from
requiring any patron or customer to
provide any documentation certifying
covid19
vaccination or post-transmission
recovery as a condition of service
so they've they've got to include this
language saying that it's it's boring
businesses
connected to interstate commerce because
the
house of representatives the congress
broadly does not have the right
to go in and interfere with the
intra-state business
so they they need to tie this to the
interstate commerce clause or the
federal government
has some say here this is important
stuff though i'm glad that the
republicans in the house
are doing everything they can to
interfere with these businesses and
protect our liberties
rep warren davidson a republican here
working on this said
they're not really providing these
businesses are not really providing a
rational basis for discriminatory
activity
they're busy separating healthy people
from other healthy people on the
presumption that people without a
vaccine are not healthy and
this is the point and he goes further to
say it's a violation of civil liberties
the point here is not an
eternal maxim that the government never
has
any right to uh or businesses never have
any right to suggest that people get the
vaccine
that people take care of their health or
anything like that
we're being very specific here what
warren davidson is saying
is that for this vaccine
the businesses do not have a right to do
this because in this case
the the science and the data do not
suggest
that this this ought to be a political
mandate
right i know we're not we're never
allowed to have nuance when we're
talking about the government versus
business
or when we're talking about one virus
versus another virus or when we're
talking about one vaccine versus another
but politics is about nuance it's about
that complexity
ideologues don't like complexity right
they want things to be very clear
shallows are clear shallow thinking is
clear
deep things are a little a little
muddier a little a little more
opaque another great move by the
republicans
in the house to to go after businesses
is what we're seeing right now in the
efforts to combat big
tech i'm not sure that i'm i will be
permitted
to to air what i just said about covid
and about the vaccine
on this show i'm not sure that youtube
will let me do it i should hope that
they would
i should hope that this that they would
let me read information from the cdc
in the fda but i don't know anymore i
know
plenty of people have been censored for
less
that's a problem you know speech is
politics since politics is speech
resist it michael do not do the plug do
no no i'm going to hold off for now
in in a republic speech is politics and
politics of speech if you control the
speech you are going to control
the politics that is what is happening
right now at the level of google
facebook and twitter they have they have
more power in this regard than the duly
elected sitting president
as they proved when they crossed the
route across the rubicon and deep
platformed donald trump
six and a half months ago so republicans
are fighting back they've got
five distinct bills that are now
overcoming some serious hurdles
to break up big tech
that sort of thing really helps me sleep
easy at night do you know what else
helps me sleep easy
my pillow products that's what i've got
to confess something i got a little
angry at my sweet newborn baby the other
day
because we're holding the baby and you
know he's such a cute little guy and
we're here we've got him in bed
and then he spits up on my giza dream
bed sheets
my beautiful my pillow giza dream bed
sheets now no the nice thing is
you can wash them and wash them and wash
them and and it's they're totally great
and they they somehow seem to get even
better with time so
the bed sheets survived but i don't want
anybody to threaten my geese or dream
bed sheets okay or any of my other
products from my pillow
just a tremendous company their products
are ultra soft breathable they're
extremely extremely durable they come
with a 60 day money back guarantee a 10
year warranty
you're not going to need the 10 year
warranty because you're going to love
the sheets the first night you sleep on
the giza sheets
you'll never want to sleep on anything
else they come in a variety of sizes and
colors
we all love my my pillow because they're
a great conservative company
but they're just the best in the
business head on over right now to
mypillow.com click on the radio listener
square
use promo code daily wire there you will
find not only this amazing offer but
lots of other deep discounts on my
pillow products
including the mattress topper the towel
sets and so much more call
1-800-951-7163 use promo code daily wire
or go to mypillow.com
use promo code dailywire five distinct
bills right now
from the republicans in the house to
break up big tech these are coming out
of committee now so
they're actually going somewhere it's
not just like a press release that's
that's not going to go anywhere
five bills just to make you aware of
them we don't need to go in depth on
these bills
but just to give you a sense of where
republicans are coming from
now and how different we are you know i
mean even 10 years ago if you complained
about google or facebook or twitter
you would have heard well just build
your own facebook build your own twitter
and then you think okay well we did
build our own twitter it was called
parlor
and then they booted us from the app
store and then the amazon removed the
web servers
now it's finally starting to come back
okay great
build your own twitter they wouldn't let
us do it so the first bill to break up
big tech
the american choice and innovation
online act
this would look to prevent quote
discriminatory conduct
by big tech corporations which would uh
stop them from giving preferential
treatment
to their own products and services you
know these these big tech companies are
just gobbling up
all different sorts of smaller companies
and you think about facebook acquiring
instagram say and and other other big
tech companies
google buying up everything right and so
this would say okay
you you can't give preferential
treatment to your own products
and and services so this is especially
important things like search
and you know google control search so
then what pops up in
in search is going to determine what
people visit on the internet
next one the platform competition and
opportunity act this would look to
prevent big tech companies from
from even having that opportunity in the
first place by preventing them from
buying companies that resemble
or enable competition so again just kind
of anti-trust stuff
next one the ending platform monopolies
act the bill would prevent big tech
corporations
from leveraging their power and
influence across multiple businesses in
pursuit of profitable advantages
with certain companies of a significant
size prohibited from engaging in another
line of business
which could present a conflict of
interest again this is just another
antitrust thing
the augmenting compatibility and
competition by enabling service
switching act that one's not quite as
easy to roll off the tongue is but that
that would be oh gosh
there it is it's the access act
uh politicians just can never resist an
acronym
it's just it's like you know the patriot
act the this the access act
uh this bill anyway i guess it's a good
act so i don't mean to make fun of it
uh this bill would uh look to enable the
transfer of personal information
from one platform to another so this
would this would reduce the cost of
switching from one platform
to another uh kind of like with your
cell phone right you're able to keep
your cell phone data and
switch it over to other cell phones
you're allowed to keep your phone number
so this would be like that for your your
digital information
your new media information big tech okay
and then finally the merger filing fee
modernization act
this would raise filing fees for mergers
which would be used to provide funding
for further anti-trust actions across
the ftc
the trade commission and the doj good
stuff i love it i hope i hope more of
this comes out
but michael it's tyranny the government
is in the businesses yeah right
if big woke corporations that
hate me and my views
and my way of life are are threatening
all those things
it doesn't make me feel any better that
they are a sort of semi-private entity
in some ways it makes me feel worse
because the government corrupt as it is
has some sort of nominal accountability
to the people
and these big tech companies do not but
michael they respond to market forces
not really not really they've gained a
critical mass they did so
largely through fraud by misrepresenting
what their product was and the way we
could use the product
and now they dominate the entire public
square
and they're they're not really
susceptible to a whole lot of market
forces not in the way that the mom and
pop on main street is
so yes this is a good use of government
to break up
the corporations who are themselves
acting as in mitch mcconnell's words
a sort of parallel government josh
hawley wants to start using the
government
josh hawley is is wants to
use our government to hold another
government accountable for its
infringements
on religious liberty and specifically on
christians
so you you know what's going on up in
canada because we've been playing a
number of
videos from the religious persecution in
canada and we've been covering the story
for months now
but but for those who haven't been
paying close attention canada
is is persecuting christians and
churches and shuttering churches
and preventing christians from gathering
and they're using the public health
measures as the excuse
but it is a it is a naked uh religious
persecution
so hawley comes out in a letter
to the chairman of the religious freedom
international watch list and he says i'm
troubled that our canadian neighbors are
effectively being forced to gather in
secret undisclosed locations to exercise
their basic freedom to worship
i would expect this sort of religious
crackdown in communist china not in a
prominent western nation like canada
canadian authorities arrest of religious
faith leaders and seizure of church
property among other enforcement actions
appears to constitute systemic ongoing
and egregious violations of religious
freedom yes i think he's right
christianity is the most persecuted
religion in the world there are many
very prominent surveys that suggest as
much and it's not
only that that is the case in africa
it's not only that that is the case in
the middle east it's true
it's true in the west as well the
persecution is a little subtler
although it's becoming less and less
subtle up in up in canada
in the united states there was the
shuttering of churches during covet
but it wasn't quite as egregious as
what's going on in canada
all of this to remind you the separation
of church and state is an
illusion not only does it appear nowhere
in the constitution not only was that
not the idea of our founding fathers
to have a firm separation between church
and state but it's also just politically
impossible
there is no such thing there has never
been a government in the history of the
world
that has no relationship to religion
because everybody's got to serve
somebody
all laws legislate morality and all
nations have to have some basic
premise some understanding of who they
are and that comes from a religious
foundation
so what we are seeing here is not
the secular state the neutral secular
irreligious state versus
christians what is what we're seeing is
a competition
between two different religions the
state established church of secular
progressivism
and the various christian churches
here in the united states and
specifically in canada
and i think this particular religious
persecution is even more dangerous and
insidious than most
because the people who are who are
perpetrating it
pretend as though they don't have any
religious point of view they're they're
blind to what they're doing speaking of
totalitarianism totalitarianism
there is real totalitarianism going on
creeping up in
in these governments but of course the
conservatives are the ones being accused
of it
which is absurd in florida
ron desantis is issuing a big
government mandate ron desantis is
issuing a mandate that is basically
could have come right out of the pages
of my new book i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna say it i'm not i've been plugging
it too much i'm not gonna say it
but this is exactly the sort of thing
that i am calling for
in my book it's i don't think ron
desantis has read it yet but it
but he got the message and very few
conservatives have gotten the message
ron desantis is passing a bill
that would force schools
right so it's a big government encroach
and if
forcing actually the curriculum here to
teach students
to learn about the evils of communism
take a listen
the bill also expands our previous
efforts in civics
to add a requirement for the high school
government class
that students receive instruction on the
evils of communism
and totalitarian ideologies we have
a number of people in in florida
particularly southern florida
who've escaped totalitarian regimes
who've escaped communist dictatorships
to be able to come to america we want
all students to understand
the difference why would somebody flee
across
shark infested water say leaving from
cuba to come to southern florida
why would somebody leave a place like
vietnam
why would people leave these countries
and risk their life to be able to come
here
it's important that students understand
that now as part of this bill
florida will create a portrait and
patriotism library
so students can learn about real
patriots who came to this country
after seeing the horrors of these
communist regimes
yes love it this might be my single
favorite bill
that we have seen out of any state in a
very very long time
the libertarians maybe are going to
freak out about this the left is
certainly going to freak out they're
going to say this is
the government coming in you
hypocritical republicans it's the
government coming in telling
the schools what to teach it's a huge
expansion of government power
no it's not no it's not it's just a
switch of the standards the government
power is not increasing the government
already
tells the schools what to teach the
schools are part of the government right
they're public schools
but right now the schools are mandated
to teach about the evils
of america and the evils of
the west and what ron desantis is saying
is
the schools actually also now have to
teach about the evils of
totalitarianism and the evils of
communist dictatorships
i love that it's not an expansion of big
government at all
it's recognizing that the battle is
actually not really between big and
small government
it's about competing standards and
competing exercises
of power what i believe to be the just
reasonable power that is being asserted
here by ron desantis
versus the unjust unreasonable power
being asserted by the proponents of
things like critical race theory and
and radical leftism more broadly
the teachers are not happy teachers all
over the country are not happy right now
forget about ron desantis for a second
they're not happy
that the right is calling out critical
race theory
there was one teacher just went viral on
tick tock
who expressed her anti-racist
fury that that conservatives and parents
are finally asserting their rights over
their kids education this is what's
[ __ ]
today is the first time our country has
recognized juneteenth
it's national holiday and yet i'm
getting ready to go back to school in
the fall
and my governor has put into place some
ridiculous
legislation that many governors across
the country put in place such as i can't
teach anything divisive
i can't teach critical race theory and i
can't teach
about racial equity this is at all
public
schools colleges and universities
so teachers in the past
we've been activists after this show of
last year
we really need to stand up and do what's
right for our kids right now so
this is a call to action teachers we got
to stand up and fight for our kids
because this is [ __ ]
we can't lie to them here's my call to
action
fire that teacher that teacher should
lose her job
but michael academic freedom
academic freedom does not mean what you
think it means
i'm a proponent of academic freedom in
the sense that
i believe scholars ought to be able to
study what they want to study
but i'm an opponent of academic freedom
if if what that means is
teachers are allowed to teach whatever
they want they're not
that's not their job teachers
are required that the the job
description of a teacher
is to teach the curriculum it's to teach
what the school has decided ought to be
taught to the students
and who decides then what ought to be
taught well
it's the parents have some say i think
the trustees have some say if
it's a public school the people have
some say the teachers have
some say in the way it's taught and
school administrators do as well
but it's not just the case that these
radical leftists
have the right to indoctrinate our
students in
insane theories and insane ideologies
such as critical race theory such as
everything else that she's describing
that woman has no right to do that that
woman has no right to her job
and if she is now calling for activism
and equity or these are all just code
words for radical leftism
i guess the activism she's talking about
is actually just a synonym for it
then she doesn't have a right to be in
the classroom
conservatives need to be willing to use
our political power also known as the
government
to go in and exercise our political
right
okay we need to be able to go in and
kick teachers like that out of the
classroom i would strongly recommend
a radical leftist teacher who is calling
for activism and who's calling
for the pushing of leftist ideology in
contravention of the law
to be fired that's a good idea and
believe it or not that
that woman is not the loopiest woman
going around
tick tock right now that award goes to
another gal
who went who went viral for
bragging about how wonderfully
anti-racist she is
for not caring for her
crying daughter so this morning the baby
woke up
and had some sort of violence in her
heart i don't know what it was but she
has been
losing her mind all day and
it's interesting because i'm watching
her
lose her mind and then i'm watching the
preteen respond to that by
trying to make her happy and
i have had to like actively tell him
stop trying to make her feel better stop
responding to her tears
it's so interesting to see the
conditioning of people responding
to white girl tears happening so early
she's
five and she's got an 11 year old coming
after her trying to make her feel better
when she cries
we have to unlearn this whole business
that white women crying is going to get
them
what they want in life because that
ain't it
oh man we need to we need to unlearn
whatever we unlearned i think i think
the preteen kind of gets it
and i think this lady has been
brainwashed
by a culture that is well that is
in this particular instance explicitly
anti-white
what would she say if well i guess she
wouldn't be in this situation
but if a five-year-old black girl were
crying
and then an 11 year old black sibling
came up and took care of the child
i by by the way that she's speaking here
you would imagine
she would say okay that's fine we should
respond to
black woman tears but not white woman
tears well it's not a woman it's a
little kid
it's a five-year-old kid who's crying
and you're supposed to come for kids who
cry
i'm not saying that there is no role for
you know saying all right toughen up kid
okay we're not going to indulge this all
the time
but but what this woman is saying is
specifically because my daughter is
white
because i'm white i'm going to
neglect her and let her cry and cry and
cry
because she is part of white supremacy
the reason that my young daughter is
crying is not because she's
a little girl it's because she's white
and feels
entitled to comfort
sick stuff folks and
that idea by the way is
being taught in the schools that idea
right now is
all part and parcel of this racial
ideology
that the radical left believes it has a
right to teach our students it's not
true
before we go we've only got just a very
little bit of time before we get to the
mailbag
i have to bring up the free britney
campaign seriously i i do this it's
actually an important political issue
britney spears has been under a the
singer has been under a conservatorship
for quite some time now where her father
is basically controlling her life
and she has just spoken to a judge she
said i'm not happy i can't sleep i'm
depressed i cry every day
i was told right now in the
conservatorship i'm not able to get
married or have a baby so
she has a birth control device called an
iud inside of her prevents her from
getting pregnant and
she wants it to be removed and her
father will not let it be removed
this is truly evil stuff this is the
kind of sick stuff
that you you hear about in the eugenics
movement which you hear about from a
century ago
the the this is the stuff you hear about
out of communist china
if practically speaking forced
sterilization
very very evil people this should if
it's not a crime already this should be
a crime and the people who are forcing
this sort of contraception on her should
should face criminal penalties for it in
a just world
i ordinary i don't really know very much
about britney spears and i'm not saying
that conservative ships are always
illegitimate but in this case this has
obviously gone too far
evil evil stuff and we actually should
as conservatives we should call
attention to it
forced sterilization whether it's
permanent or
or just effectively permanent she can't
take it out that is some really really
evil stuff
you can read about all these complex
issues how we've been
so just duped in the last several
decades
in my book i'm just going to do it one
more time there it is okay you heard it
speechless i do i want you know i've
plugged it so much i'm going to retire
the bell
but i want to thank everyone who has uh
ordered the book
uh you can get the signed first edition
of premiere collectibles i believe it's
sold out but
they may be getting some more in so
that's where the signed first edition is
you can get just a regular old edition
at amazon barnes noble
all over the place i really really want
to stick it in the eye
of the new york times and the squishes
for that matter too
but so i appreciate everyone who has
pre-ordered the book and ordered the
book and who is sending me in their
photos reading the book and
and that's really great who are leaving
five star reviews on amazon
thank you very much uh get your copy if
you haven't done it already also despite
this film's popularity
of created equal this movie by clarence
thomas amazon inexplicably removed it
from its streaming platform
during none other than black history
month lucky for you
the daily wire has decided to step in we
are streaming it ourselves so get your
popcorn ready because you can now stream
create it equal the clarence thomas
movie any
time it's available to daily wire
members over at dailywire.com if you're
not a daily wire member join
now at dailywire.com subscribe with
codejustice
for 20 off your membership get ready for
a film
unlike any other once you're a member be
sure to check out all of our other great
content including
our talk show canvas featuring candace
owens including run hide fight
and bench bureau's new series debunked
you can get all of this and more on
demand by going to dailywire.com
subscribe check out with 20
off using code justice start streaming
today we'll be right back with the
mailbag
first question up from jessica hey
michael i heard your answer about the
law of attraction
and wanted to ask more about it i was
trying out manifesting recently
and thought it to be benign on the
surface think positively and believe
that what you want life is possible
i've noticed that some things i simply
thought about occurring did happen
but i don't believe it was without god's
hand would that just be providence i
have quit with the law of attraction
since your initial response
but would love to hear your thoughts on
how to recognize providence
and how you can more clearly see it in
your life sincerely positive and
prayerful vibes only okay
for those who didn't hear the first time
or who are unfamiliar with this
the law of attraction and the idea of
manifestation is part of a new
new age cult that is uh that suggests
that you can control the universe with
your mind
and this was uh popularized by this book
that oprah
plugged called the secret this is really
bad stuff folks
do not do it do not get involved in it
you are dealing with forces that are
that are you you
should not be messing with uh this is
just a
sorcery basically this is the sort of
thing that in the bible in the olden
times
would have been called sorcery or
witchcraft and now we
just call it new age kookiness but
there's a big difference between
manifestation and the law of attraction
and providence
manifestation and the law of attraction
is your insistence
that you can make demands of god and
that god
must submit to your demands
by by enabling things in the created
world to succumb to your will
this is making yourself into god
and things do not turn out well when you
try to do that
this is the the lie told by the serpent
in the garden of eden which i write
about in my book
do not do not do that sort of thing
providence
is recognizing that there is an order to
the universe that god who is outside of
time and space
sees all things absent time and all
things happen in god's due
time the way that my my good friend
father george rutler described it as
in his book coincidentally which is a
good book on the topic of providence
he he says it's an evil generation that
looks for signs and wonders
but it's a stupid generation that
ignores signs and wonders
so you can see the way things work
together in life you can see the hand of
providence our founding fathers wrote
about this
at great length the pilgrims on the
mayflower wrote about this
many many people in history have written
about providence
but providence is not demanding that god
submit to your will quite the opposite
actually it's recognizing
that god's will is is what orders the
universe
and with god will and reason are united
because god is the divine logic of the
universe
total totally the opposite thing from
this new age cult
and the secret and the laws of
attraction and the manifestation and all
that stuff do not
do not mess with that from verinder hey
michael
you said you have an issue in
referencing transgender people's new
names
to match their new gender such as bruce
becoming caitlyn
would you have the same issue when
someone changes their name for religious
reasons
like muhammad ali changing his name from
cassius clay
good question i do not have the same
issue
not saying there's no issue i guess the
problem with uh cassius clay
changing his name is that he was
converting to a religion that i
you know i do not subscribe to i would
not therefore i could would not
recommend someone do that
but it's a very very different thing a
man
changing his name to another man's name
for religious reasons
is not the same thing as a man changing
his name to a woman's name
because he's pretending to be a woman
there is no
violation of reality by by someone
uh switching up their religion
coming into what they believe to be the
fullness of truth now
you know not all religions are true so
that
that creates problems for the individual
but there's no
issue with that sort of a name change
for goodness sakes the first pope
changed his name
actually our lord changed the first
pope's name when he said
simon you are now peter and on this rock
i'll build my church so that's
i'm totally cool with that
but caitlyn is a woman's name it's i
know we
it's it's a sort of social construction
i suppose but it is a woman's name
and to call a man caitlyn is to
suggest that a man sort of can become a
woman i i just don't think that's
possible and i don't think as a society
we should embrace that sort of thing
good question
but i think we're talking about very
very different things
one of those switches is not making
claims on reality from chase
uh michael or one of those changes is
not making claims on reality that are
manifestly not true
from chase michael at the beginning of
this week you showed a clip
where a girl was explaining all the
rules she goes by to express her own
gender ideology
the clip reminded me of the lie the
serpent told in the garden about how we
would be like god
i have interpreted this lie to mean that
we can dictate reality and
make spoken word truth wow talk about
providence what are the odds that this
question would come up after what we
were just talking about
i'm writing because i want to know if
this is a good argument to make toward
my christian friends who are not as
engaged in this conversation of gender
ideology as they perhaps should be
do you believe that this is a good
position to argue as as to why gender
ideologies such as this
are sinful or does it seem a bit too
heavy-handed and or a bit of a stretch
no i think this is a perfect example
this is it
transgenderism is the new manifestation
of the gnostic heresy
and you see i mean gnosticism is the
secret right
they actually mean the same thing
gnosticism just literally means secret
knowledge and
it's what you're seeing with new age
cults like
like the secret or with older cults like
albigensianism or marcianism or
manichaeism
and transgenderism is just yet another
expression of that
and yes it is an attempt to be as god as
it is an attempt
to um to empower oneself
uh over over the world in a nefarious
way
so yes i i think you're totally on the
money good stuff
from noah dear michael i love the show i
listen to it every day in my job oh
thank you very much
i'm a proud conservative christian and
i've been having quite a lot of trouble
finding a fine girlfriend
every time i find a nice girl she's
always got another man
however i did find a beautiful girl from
my church at home
good news there is not another man in
the way but the bad news is that i feel
that she friend zoned me
she told me that she is currently not
looking to be in a relationship but my
gesture flatters her
i know the lord says he shuts doors no
one can open
but i would like to know is this a shut
door
for a hurdle i am meant to jump and thus
keep pursuing her thank you
i don't know that's the most insightful
answer i can give you
because there is not some hard and fast
rule here
every pickup artist
hustler in the world thinks that women
are basically just
all very simple creatures and you just
follow three steps
and then you can pick up any girl you
want that's not how women really are
that's not how love really is and and
relationships to use the modern world
really are it may well be the case that
this gal is just 100 not interested in
you at all
in my single days i pursued girls who
just they just weren't interested in me
and i thought i you know got somewhere
for a little bit
and then it i didn't you know and then
that's that and no amount of
perseverance is going to do anything
it'll probably only humiliate you and
pester her
now sometimes there are girls who say
you know i'm not not really interested
and you can kind of win them over you
can woo them that's good
that's a nice thing it's possible and
then sometimes it really clicks right at
once
i would not recommend totally giving up
if you really are interested in this
girl
but likewise you have no right to her
time and interest and
it might just be the case that you ain't
her she might be your type
but you ain't her type and so one way
that i would perhaps
try to explore this is just by being
cool just be cool man
just be cool be confident
be upfront about your interest in her
don't be creepy about it don't be weird
about it but just you know yeah no i
like
you're great you're cute you know let's
go i'd be great to get a drink but hey
you're not interested it's no big deal
i would i would explore other options
you know
i would pursue other women and
the girl might come around so i wouldn't
deny your interest in her i wouldn't
um i i wouldn't allow the the friend
zone to
have you imply that you're not
interested in her at all but also
you know a man who is really
romantically interested in a woman
should not really i don't even think
it's really possible
to to be a just a regular old friend
with her i mean that would put you in a
really degraded situation where
you know you're her gal pal or something
i wouldn't do that you know you've made
it
your interest clear you perhaps can
continue to make your interest clear but
if she ain't interested
then you got to move on from maya hey
michael i'm graduating high school next
year and lots of people say that college
is a waste of time and money
i've also heard lots of people say it's
great what are your thoughts on it if
not college then what
i wanted to become a social worker but
the more i think about it i don't feel
like dealing with all the people i would
have
oh well then don't be a social worker
it's very
very hard job if you're already having
doubts like this thanks for doing what
you are doing and being a great resource
for myself and many
should you go to college what do you
want to do
some conservatives will tell you you
should only go to college if you're
going to major in some practical
skill like engineering or stem
i think that's bs and ridiculous and i
strongly disagree with that point of
view
i actually think the opposite i think
that you should go get a liberal
education if you want a liberal
education
if you want to go to college because you
want to understand your own freedom
and your own culture and become a
well-read person
and make sense of very difficult
philosophical and literary and
historical subjects
then great college is a great place to
do it but there are only a handful of
colleges left that will give you that
education
being in places like hillsdale ave maria
thomas aquinas college franciscan of
steubenville a few others
will really offer you a proper liberal
education now some other
colleges and universities will offer you
other stuff if you want to be an
investment banker
or a top you know mckinsey consultant
then you should go to yale or harvard or
princeton or something like that
i suppose in a way you might be able to
get a liberal education at those schools
but it's going to be a little harder to
suss out you know
the advantage of those schools is people
there tend to have very high iqs but
a lot of them get just involved in
really leftist politics and don't don't
really care about their studies
so if you if you want that sort of thing
you go there if you want
to learn a practical skill say you want
to become an electrician
then you should go to a trade school if
you want to become a lawyer
then you will have to go to a college
but you should aim that at your
i suppose it's your plans afterward
we once understood that education has a
purpose
we don't do that anymore though now
college is just about
what you do next you just you graduate
high school and then you go to college
and you party and do a lot of things
that you shouldn't do
and then maybe you'll figure out what
you want to do afterward we must
recognize
everything has a purpose whether we
recognize it or not and we should
we should pursue things toward good ends
i hope that helps from tyler hey mr
knowles i'm a conservative in august
i'll be attending a very liberal college
i was wondering if you have any advice
for me should i sit back and bite my
tongue for a good grade or should i
challenge my professors
when they push their liberal ideas onto
the class
you do not need to be flamboyant in your
views you don't need to wear the maga
hat every single day
but likewise i would not hide your views
i would not
it was at least i would say i would not
lie
about your views i would have integrity
i would have courage
that might cost you grades i know people
always write in they say
hey how do i get perfect grades and get
invited to every party and also be
totally outspoken my political views
you probably can't everything has a
price everything has a cost but
integrity is a nice thing dignity is a
nice thing i wouldn't sell it out
so that you can get an a instead of an a
minus or so that you can get invited
to some party hope everybody enjoys the
the appropriate parties this weekend
i'm michael knowles the michael knowles
show see you on monday
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadofsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coromina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 hey everybody
this is andrew clavin host of the andrew
clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching
and the moons turn to blood but on the
andrew clavin show that's where the fun
just gets started so come on over to the
andrew clavin show and laugh your way
through the fall of the republic with me
andrew clavin